unfortunately there are some truths that
are disheartening and what we have to do
is realistically work from that point to
try to come up with some kind of a
solution that is actually workable
rather than Retreat into fantasies Hal
truths and deceptions that are much more
comforting much more heartening but
unfortunately
false now in this case if there is a
permanent state of War existing between
the uh House of Islam the D Al Islam and
the house of war the D Al har which is
us then it is because Muslims who
believe these teachings are waging it
and always have been waging it and the
only times in history when there has not
been widespread Jihad violence in the
world is at times when the Islamic
community was too weak to put it forward
but not because there was any
large-scale reform of these teachings
rejection of these teachings even
reconsideration of these
teachings this is not to say that every
Muslim in the world is our enemy should
be our enemy orever will be fighting
against us because as in in Islam as in
every other religious tradition there is
a spectrum of belief of knowledge and a
fervor there are many millions of people
around the world billions in fact who
call themselves Christians and yet to
assume that they all agree on Christian
doctrine or that they all will act upon
Christian doctrines that they agree on
would be absurd there is a huge
variation in how those people who call
themselves Christians live out their
Christianity or are Christians
essentially a name only and ignore part
or all of it it's the same way in Islam
these things are teachings of all the
schools of Islamic law these things are
manifestly taught in the Quran they are
taught in the example of Muhammad who
has the perfect example the Supreme
excellent example of conduct as
specified in the Quran is to be imitated
held up as a model for emulation in
Islamic Theology and as these things are
taught then there are people who will
take them seriously there are people who
will not take them seriously there are
people who will hear them and believe
them but not be willing to give up their
comfortable lives they just want to have
a job and a family they just want to be
left alone they don't really can't
really be bothered with all these
theological
issues there is also because of the
Great Western influence including the
influence of Western pop culture which
has been so derided in the Islamic World
there is also a widespread acceptance of
Western Sentiments of Western Notions of
human rights that are at variance with
classical Notions of Islamic law the
Quran not Spencer not uh some extremists
mandates amputation of the hand for
theft that's chapter 5:38 uh the Hadith
the Islamic traditions and Islamic law
are unanimous on that they are unanimous
on the stoning of adulterers they are
unanimous on the institutionalized
subjugation of women in many ways but
the world is not the Islamic world is
not hermetically sealed Western ideas
have come in and there are millions
hundreds of millions of Muslims who do
subscribe to Western Notions of Human
Rights Western Notions of the Dignity of
all people and the equality of Rights of
all people before the law these people
can be our allies but both within the
Islamic world and in terms of the
Islamic world's relations to the West
these things cannot come about if if we
don't acknowledge the situation first
you can't reform what you won't admit
needs reforming you can't fix what you
won't admit as broken the reformers such
as khed Abu alad whom Dr Peterson
mentioned are actually uh people who are
not the kind of reformer you would
expect if you're familiar with European
history you're familiar with the
Protestant Reformation whether you are a
Catholic or a Protestant or whether you
were neither then you may know that the
Protestant reformers pointed out
elements of Catholic theology that they
rejected and they taught against them
they fought against them they said we do
not believe and we do not think that the
church ought to teach transubstantiation
papal Authority veneration of Mary and
so on they did not
say these elements of Christianity do
not exist and have never existed and
anybody who thinks so is just helping
the
extremists and it's the same way today
if we're going to really help genuine
Islamic reformers we shouldn't pre then
we cannot take those people and there
are many including some that Dr Peterson
mentioned who were saying that these
elements of Islam do not exist and have
never
existed that's not reform that's
deception we can take as allies those
who say there are these elements of
Islam and they need to be rethought
there needs to be a fundamental
reassessment of how we take even the
literal words of the Quran and there may
need to be a retreat from an explicit
Retreat from literalism in several
particulars but this problem will never
go away this problem will not be solved
this problem will continue to recur if
we in the first place forbid ourselves
from speaking about it and we are end up
pretending that it doesn't exist and
accepting the comforting half-truths and
inaccurate formulations of people who
have not actually confronted the reality
of these things just for example Dr
Peterson mentioned that uh there are
interpretations of the Quran that are
put forward by the jihadists today and
that I am endorsing ing them and
validating them supposedly by writing
about them and Reporting on them and
that he reminds me that we have to take
into account
theb which is the context of the various
verses of the Quran well let me give you
a little lesson in asbab naul right here
just very
briefly IB isak the first biographer of
Muhammad in the 8th Century a Pious
Muslim explains the contexts of various
quranic verses about Warfare not
necessarily about Jihad as Dr Peterson
points out quite rightly Jihad means
struggle there are many struggles in
Arabic just as there are many struggles
in English you can struggle to quit
smoking and you can have a great
struggle against the Communist world
it's the same word but there's no doubt
that Jihad Warfare is an element of this
and there's more Ian isak says there are
there are places in the Quran where
Muhammad the Quran teaches peace Surah
109 of the Quran says you have say to
the unbelievers you have your religion
and I have mine essentially let's leave
each other alone that's great I would I
I can go for that but iban isak says
there are also portions of the Quran
which teach Warfare which say fight
against those who have fought against
you but do not begin hostilities and
then there's that's chapter 2 verse 190
and then there are further passages such
as chapter 9: 29 which says fight
against the people of the book that's
Jews and Christians primarily until they
pay the jizya which is the tax the
religion-based tax specified in Islamic
law withen willing submission and feel
themselves subdued in other words fight
against the Jews and Christians until
they submit to the rule of the Muslims
now Ian isak says in context the first
set of verses vers uh the ones that are
broadly tolerant came from the early
part of Muhammad's career when he was a
preacher he was not a military leader
and he was essentially powerless then
when he moved to Medina and he became
for the first time a political and
military leader he began to tell the
Muslims to defend themselves and that's
the second stage of quranic Revelation
according to Ian isak not to Spencer of
the teachings on Jihad and finally he
says that the Quran because the Muslims
are the best of people that's chapter 3:
110 and the unbelievers are the most
vile of created beings that's chapter
98:6 therefore the Muslims must fight in
order to extend their hegemony over the
the world because this is the law of God
and they have the responsibility to
spread the law of God everywhere now in
other words what he's saying is that
there three stages of chonic development
on warfare and the third and final stage
that is applicable for all time is
Warfare against unbelievers I didn't
make that up that is the earliest
biographer of Muhammad every biographer
of Muhammad since then including Dr
Peterson has to rely at least in part on
his writings and that theological point
that he makes about the context of the
quranic verses is mainstream Islam
taught by all the schools of Islamic law
I am all for Muslims who reject that I
am all for Muslims who say we have to
move beyond that but I do not trust
Muslims who say that does not exist and
that is not so that is not reform again
that is deception we need not to be
deceived here we cannot afford to allow
ourselves to be deceived and as Muhammad
said war is deceit and that war
deception deliberate lying is allowed in
times of warfare in which we are
manifestly in one today or many Muslims
believe we are and when when Muslims are
under pressure from unbelievers as
specified by Quran 3:28 they may pretend
to be their friends
while actually working against them
these things have to be recognized as
being elements of quranic teaching the
teachings of Muhammad the teachings of
Islamic law without that first
recognition there can be no genuine
reform and no genuine movement toward
any kind of resolution of this conflict
and one thing we can be certain certain
of in that event is that if voices like
Dr Peterson's Prevail the war will
continue and intensify for the
foreseeable future thank
[Applause]
you